all right let's continue here um yeah he
just had too much going on let's go to
John from Jersey John what's going on
today
David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
uh so you've been talking a lot lately
about anti-Semitism which is a subject I
think about a lot
um so I I'm a copt uh which is a
Christian ethno religious group mostly
from Egypt yes uh so growing up around
other cops uh I always heard some dark
anti-semitic comments like you know a
lot of it with the whole you know Christ
killer or sometimes you know they have
the evil eye they're pale with no soul
yeah and as vile and as vile as these
comments are what really puzzles me is
the phenomenon of the typical tropes
like uh you know they stick together and
help each other you know they're they're
cheap
um you know and and
um what's hypocritical about this is a
lot of these like common tropes are
actually traits that are in the Coptic
community and they're almost like
revered except you know you're not
called cheap you're called like Frugal
and like uh you know uh crafty and and
things like that uh you're not called uh
uh you know that something bad about
sticking together no you you know you're
part of a community uh right so I just
wanted to take you one of the funny ones
sorry sorry to interrupt but one of the
funny ones is you know when people go oh
Jew Jews they just love money it's like
right black people hate money white
people hate money Italian people hate
money Jews are the ones that love money
it's just it's all so stupid
yeah so I mean I mean it's it's uh it's
very transparent and hypocritical I I
why why is it that it's something that's
that's still a trade among you know
really most most people
which part is a trade the the having
beliefs or what yeah well I guess I
guess the the
um like hate for Jews like wow what is
it what is it that makes Jews uh so
unique or or the focal point of uh of
you know the whole world really there's
a bunch of factors here so let's I'll
list some of them okay
there are historical factors which
blaming Jews for thousands of years has
been a shorthand that can be used
whenever there's a problem is it they're
responsible for the plague or they're
responsible for Killing Jesus or they're
responsible for
um uh the American college and
universities becoming left-wing whatever
so first of all it's it's just it's been
a shorthand for a long time too as you
mentioned many of the tropes actually
sort of apply to everyone but and so
when so it's very easy to say oh well
you know Jews love money and are cheap
it's like most people like money and try
to avoid spending more money than they
need to but when it's only applied to
one group you can very easily find what
you're looking for that's a second thing
third thing there is a difference with
some Jews remember there's some Jews are
darker skinned lighter skin whatever in
Western societies it's true that in many
cases you can't tell by looking at
someone whether they're Jewish obviously
most Jews aren't wearing a yamaka or
peace or you know all these different
things so you can't tell when you look
at someone and to some of these
anti-semites that becomes part of why
they are targeted because it's seen
almost as part of the deception you know
they walk around Among Us and you can't
even tell who's who someone's a woman
you can tell by looking at them if
someone's black you can tell by looking
at them Etc so it almost feeds upon its
own Trope about the idea of deception
and hiding out in plain sight and so all
these different little historical and
modern realities and then there's
another thing which people love to talk
about this oh well why are Jewish folks
over represented in some Industries and
they love to talk about law or
entertainment or whatever
right there's a historical
discrimination reason why that's the
case Jews were banned for so long and in
so many places from participating in so
many industries that there was this de
facto push to concentrate in Industries
where you can not necessarily have to
physically engage with certain
industries in particular ways and it's
because of discrimination that you now
see some of that phenomena today not
because of Any Grand conspiracy to
control Industries as anti-semites often
say it's because of discrimination where
Jews were crossed off from a whole bunch
of Industries you can't be here you
can't be here you can't be here okay
well what's left
right right uh that that's something
similar to a lot of other uh uh trades
or uh professions like you know uh Irish
Americans uh in the law enforcement
Community sure things like that yep
um thanks David thanks for giving me
your take on this uh I appreciate you
have time for another question you know
we are out of time okay thanks for
taking my call all right your first one
was good though so I really appreciate
it all right everybody we're gonna go to
a break sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again